I welcome Bishop to another tournament
here in st. Louis mm-hmm
thank you I wanted to ask you a couple
of questions very quick first one how
does it feel to travel so far for such a
quick tournament well that's why I came
a few days early because at the feeling
that I would need at least a couple of
days to get over jetlag but it's not a
big problem it seems like chess in India
is unstoppable for the first time you
have two players in the top ten how do
you think this is going to affect your
personal career or do you see it
affecting you at all do you think you'll
play at any point for the team well
maybe but obviously I'm very happy with
in fact that now we have two players in
the top ten and we may well have three
and three or four in the top hundred as
well and so it's very good progress by
firing on all cylinders
all right but no mention about whether
you'll play in the team at some point or
is that not really something you're
interested in I'm not a big fan of
Olympians as people who probably figured
out but let's see let's see what happens
in infinity